we are on problem 56.
scott is constructing a line
perpendicular to line l
from point p fair enough which of the
following should be his first step so he
wants to draw a line that looks
something like this
he wants to draw you know going straight
up through the point p
and so how do you do that obviously if
you just use a ruler maybe by accident
you draw it a slight angle or something
like that right so he wants to have an
exact line
so let's see i don't even know what he's
doing in this first one he's drawing
these x's i don't know what how he's
determining where those x's go so that
step one that a doesn't look right
step b
step b it looks like he kind of picked
two points
and is drawing and using his compass to
pivot off of those to kind of draw arcs
there
but that's still not clear how it could
help i mean if he knew that
you know he could do some math and try
to figure out that these are equidistant
from p and but still i mean you what he
wants to do is find a point right around
there right below p
where if he draws a line between p and
that point it'll be perpendicular so
that doesn't seem to be of much help
here he picked a point and he's drawing
an arc but that arc doesn't really tell
me much information
let me see d
this looks interesting so
he took it looks like he took the pivot
of his compass and he drew a circle
around with a constant radius obviously
that's what makes it a circle
and then what he could do now
is he could take his pivot he could he
could mark each of these points
right
if he marked each of those points
and
and just pivoted around them and and
drew a circle
he would actually so let's say that
around that point he would pivot and the
circle looks something like
um i don't know and he would want to
change the radius a little bit so let's
say it looks something like this
i'm going to try my best to draw it
so say it looks something like that
and then around that point he does the
same thing
he pivots around it
i guess the two would have to be big
enough to intersect with each other
right but where the point that they do
intersect i know i'm drawing it really
horrible
the point at which they do intersect
would be equidistant between those two
points
right and another way to think about it
would be another point that's
equidistant between the two points
because
when you do it first with p and you draw
that circle you're saying oh wow both of
these points are going to be equidistant
from p right just by definition right
this is a circle and that's a constant
radius and then if you take each of
those points and draw
circles or draw arcs so let's say from
that one you draw an arc like that and
from that one you draw an arc like
that
you'd say wow this point is also going
to be of a constant distance from both
of them
so if i were to draw a line between both
of these points using a straight edge
that line will be perpendicular to line
l
so if i were to just do that then it
would be perpendicular so i think d is
the first step
all right problem 57
which triangle can be constructed using
the following steps okay this is
interesting a lot of compass work here
put the tip of the compass on point a
so let me go down there so they put the
tip of the compass on point a
open the compass so that the pencil tip
is on point b okay pencil tip is here
draw arc above a b so then they drew
this arc right here draw arc above a b
that's this thing that i'm
trying to color in
fair enough
without changing the opening
put the metal tip on point b so now you
put the pivot there and draw an arc of
intersecting and draw an arc
intersecting the first point at c
so now they want us to draw that second
let me do another color they're going to
draw that second arc
all right
okay now draw ac and bc all right now
what have we drawn
so when you draw this first arc i mean
on arc it's you know what they drew is
really a semi-circle right the radius is
constant so if the radius is constant
you know that
this distance right here that distance
is going to be equal to
this distance right they're just both
radiuses
of this semi-circle or of this arc
they're just radiuses right they're the
equal to the length of the opening of
our compass so that's going to be equal
to that and then when you put the pivot
here
and you keep the distance the same so
now the pencil edge goes here
right the distance is still there and
now when you do this arc
you now know that this length is equal
to this length because now they are both
radiuses they are both radiuses of this
second arc so now you know all three
sides are equal so we have to be dealing
this is this is an equilateral triangle
equilateral
d
okay
the diagram shows triangle abc fair
enough
which statement would prove that abc is
a right triangle is a right triangle and
just eyeball i mean you know this is
clearly not a right angle this is this
is probably the with the right angle for
the right triangle
and this is something that maybe you
learned in algebra class and if you
didn't you're about to learn it right
now but if i wanted to find
and i'm looking at the choices they talk
a lot about slope
so if i want to find
if i just have a line
let's say here it has slope m
and i want to say what is the slope of a
line that is perpendicular to this
to this line right here
well then well it would look like that
right it would be perpendicular it would
have a 90 degree angle and its slope
would be the negative inverse the
negative inverse of this first slope
right
so if the slope from a to b if the slope
from a to b is a negative inverse of the
slope from b to c then we're in business
then these are definitely perpendicular
at least line segments and this would be
a 90 degree angle
so let's see
slope a so what did i say slope
slope a b
or we could say
we could say slope bc
of segment bc
should be equal to the negative inverse
of the slope
slope
from a
to b
see if we multiply both sides of that
times the slope a b you get
slope
a b
times
slope bc
is equal to negative one i just
multiplied both sides equation times
slope of a b
and if we go
here
choice b is exactly what we wrote right
there
next problem 59
figure a b c
o
is a parallelogram fair enough that's
parallel to that
that's parallel to that
what are they asking us
what are the coordinates of the point of
intersection of the diagonals so what
are these coordinates
and we've mentioned it before the but
the big kind of um i guess crux of this
problem or what you need to know is that
for any parallelogram the diagonals
bisect each other they bisect each other
so that means that the distance from
here to here
from o to the midpoint or from i
shouldn't say the midpoint from o to the
intersection point is equal to the
intersection point to b and so this
intersection point is the midpoint it is
bisected by line
ac and similarly you can make the
argument
that this line segment right here is
equal to
is congruent to that line segment
so if well let's just do the if if if we
want to find if this is really the
midpoint between o and b
then we just have to find the midpoint
of their coordinates and the way to find
the the midpoint of two coordinates is
actually very intuitive you just average
the coordinates
right so if i were to average
the x's between b so let's see
if if i were to average the x's
so the x-coordinate here is going to be
the x coordinate of point b which is a
plus c
plus the x coordinate of the origin
which is zero
over two because i have two points that
i'm averaging so that's going to be the
x coordinate this is going to be and
then the y coordinate is going to be the
y coordinate of b
so that's b
plus the y coordinate of the origin i'm
just averaging them the y coordinate of
the origin is 0 divided by 2.
this will give me the coordinate of the
midpoint between origin
and b and so that equals what a plus c
over 2 and then b
over 2. so this is
this is right here
a plus c
over 2 right and that makes sense
because a plus c is going to be here
someplace
and we just took the average of the two
between 0 and that and you got the
midpoint and then the y coordinate is
going to be b over 2
which makes sense because that up there
is b and we're just halfway between b
and b and zero
right so this is a plus c over two b
over two
and is that one of the choices a plus c
and b i'm assuming that they want us to
do choice c and they just forgot to type
the b in there
this is supposed to be a b
because this is definitely not right
that's not right and we know that this
is right but it's not a plus something
over on this it's just b over 2 on the y
coordinate so that's not right all right
problem 60. i tried to
try to squeeze it in i don't know if you
can see the whole problem but it says
what type of triangle is formed by the i
think that gets cut off for you formed
by the points
a is four comma two
b is six comma negative one and c is
negative one comma three so i think the
best thing is to just try to graph it at
least start getting an intuition and
then we can see the distances between
the points and hopefully figure out what
type of triangle it is so let's see some
of the points get a little bit negative
we have a negative so let me i have to
draw some of the negative quadrants
so if i were to draw it like that
okay
and let's see
so 4 comma 2. so if i were to say
comma 1
that's right there that's point a
then i have six comma negative one
so four
five
six comma negative one negative one is
right there
that's point b
i don't know if you can see it down
there and c is negative one comma three
so
negative one
comma three
so it's out here
negative one comma three
okay now let me connect the dots
that's one side that's another side
and that's the other side so off the bat
i mean i just know this isn't going to
be a right triangle it's not an
equilateral triangle and if
the only way it's going to be an
isosceles triangle is if this length is
equal to that length so let's just try
it let's just test it out
so what is the distance from
a to c
right
well the distance is equal to or we can
say the distance squared but let's say
the distance squared from a to c
is equal to
the differences in their x's so four
minus negative one so there's a
difference of five right so there's a
difference in their x's squared
plus a difference in their y's
so two
and three
you can say two minus three or three
minus two doesn't matter we just care
about the difference 1 squared
plus 1 squared so the distance squared
is
so the distance squared is equal to 25
plus 1 is equal to 26.
so this distance is the square root of
26. and the distance between a and b
same logic
let's see when you go from the distance
squared
the difference is in their x's six
between six and four you have a distance
of two so it's two squared
plus the difference in their y's two and
negative one are three apart right plus
three
squared
and so that is equal to
four
plus nine which is equal to thirteen so
this is equal to the square root of
thirteen
okay this number this number down here
you can figure it out i'm just going to
be bigger than all of the both of them
right you can just look at it and say
that so this is definitely a scalene
triangle all of the sides are different
anyway see in the next video